[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody we're back or I'm back
usually if it's me and Joey that can
only mean one thing but that's actually
not until next week we'll be back next
week for overwatch when winter
wonderland comes out as well as the new
skins but today we're finally gonna get
our hands on the Dragonball Fighters
beta because we couldn't play over the
weekend at least we weren't gonna be
here to play on the weekend so
fortunately enough Namco I'm already
matchmaking just so you know okay Namco
has been fortunate enough to give one
more day of open beta so if you guys are
interested you can go out and download
it I think you have seven more hours to
play give or take I think and it's at 9
p.m. today so here we are in the lobby
we've queued for matchmaking so fun fact
I didn't match me for the last like 5 to
7 minutes and I only got two matches I'd
cancelled them both because we didn't
start stream yet so it took me roughly
about five to 10 minutes to finally get
one match but then I feel like once I
got my first match they started to kind
of come more frequently I lowered your
latency setting from like four bars to
like the one that's like three or higher
okay but you can always change that or
like decide if you want to fight someone
or not all right
put it on ranked instead of casual I
don't know if that makes a difference
either because I think more people are
probably playing casual matches you
think so yeah all right then go casual
them casuals filthy casuals I'm just
gonna do I can't be the same or stronger
matter anything goes I think goes no we
don't want any Weaver yeah we want some
traumatic finishes Joey if you guys
don't know what traumatic finishes are
Joey has put out a video that showcases
some of those but it basically kind of
gives you like anime moments you know
like essentially but yeah I'll be in the
chat I'll probably a few matches later
but I'm gonna let Joey primarily play
here in the beginning if you have
questions in YouTube or twitch chat send
them over my way and I will send them to
Joey or I'll try to answer them I've
only played probably less than ten
matches give or take what about you you
probably played at CSUN alone yeah
probably
maybe a little bit over a dozen I was
able to get into but we just also
experiment the game like the training
mode a little bit mm-hmm just gonna do
laps until we find a match
also the yeah that's what I was doing
also the game does come out next week on
the 26 just so you know and so how come
an SS j to Goku is on the boxart when he
isn't in the game hard to say maybe
maybe there is a version of ssj2 Goku
though in the game which one ssj2
cuz he's definitely has ssj3 as a super
didn't think that didn't think that kind
of question was coming oh you're gonna
be the one to have to answer all these
questions because oh yeah you're not hey
I might have I played black Goku
technically yes I have played black oku
only because we have review copy but I
can't really talk about that one so I
have played it though is that like your
avatar yeah why don't you show avatar
stuff I think you can do that while
still match anything so well you can't
actually my posit Oh positive but you
know I'll just go through Bungie just do
it anyway yeah like so for the lobby
here you can actually customize your
character oh we're trying to play a
battle Daniel we're trying so I got cell
right here and
under your customized options you can
actually select your Lobby character and
colors of those carry yeah so you go
hold the whole cast choose from and you
can unlock them while like I think it
was their version of like loot crate's
or something like that where you can
unlock like more of these as you play
well I'll change mine he's a good one
that's up to you Bob the camera should
be good so maybe it's on your end
hopefully not
and how do you play this beta ask
Christian Lander so you go into
PlayStation Store Xbox Store and look
for it and download it for PlayStation I
was able to find it in the free section
I think searching didn't actually help
me find it but I'm sure it's it's in a
couple spots if you had it before we
download the beta from this weekend it
should update for this one we are not
having super luck right now searching
but it's okay like I said it takes a
couple minutes to get a match and then
like you can rematch that person yeah if
they're willing and then like I said I
kind of kept getting matches like
relatively quickly after that so you get
seven more hours today to play it for
free until it comes out next week I
don't think they're having another beta
unless they decide otherwise but yeah I
see someone chat Doc's the Fox is asking
the game is 3v3 but kini have more than
one human player on a team they've
actually been dynamic was actually
mentioned something about 3v3
fights with six players at once I don't
think that's gonna be implemented yet
there might be something like down the
road but it's promising that they
actually have that on their minds at
least that's gonna be really cool if
they get that in here
gube says set your filters to any match
can you do that I thought you had to
pick ranked or casual do I do I cancel
this one should I go back in
put connection strengthen all if you put
it on high it takes much longer the
connection bar doesn't matter at most
I don't know I've seen somebody here in
the office that name is John Luke was
telling me he had a frame drop stuff but
that's fine we'll try this and go
anything goes anything knows I guess
anything goes we're gonna regret it
though problem you could set regions in
previous bit yeah we set our region so I
set it to West Coast instead at least
coast to kind of help with latency we
have a pretty full lobby also that match
makes it pause all day yeah yeah and he
seems like any menu and going to Dane
333 says even poor connections still
plays very well so just set it on
anything all right we set it on anything
so we'll see we shall see like I said it
did take me a couple minutes of like
actually after being in the queue for a
while to like actually get a match but
that's fine who are your favorite
characters from beta from the beta from
beta um I really like Frieza like even
when we play them like months ago he was
it was a pretty cool I still like to
stick with them I think nap is pretty
cool
he's a little bit tricky to play I think
just because he doesn't have like the
range or like a lot of the crazy like
flashy attacks that well the other of
sanzu but I like his just I like BP
characters okay you like that you like
that Bron yeah that's beerus are you
gonna play oh there we go options so
you're gonna are you Oh God rebar let's
go hey so if it lags I'm blaming chat
okay you guys said anything goes it
doesn't matter okay let's see if he
actually quit skipping my question why
why would I ask that question I'm gonna
time you out
just time this guy over here you're on a
time huh let's keep it a little clean
here all right ladies and gentlemen not
I'm not digging that stupid question he
has a Kirlian Napa
dramatic opener and Yamcha Napa dramatic
finish our great yep there's a pretty
cool those got shown for like a hot
second and then got pulled unfortunately
funky rock but there are a bunch we're
still trying to figure some other ones
out because I'm sure there's more in the
game we just haven't figured them all
out yet so the triggers that we know or
it's it's some type of character or team
specific like team in the sense that you
might not be able to have somebody right
yeah on the team and then it has to be
like level specific and then for a
finisher it has to be those two
characters and then like finish with a
hard attack yeah heart attack on the
specific stage like it's funny because
like even if you pick that stage in the
beginning it can always transition to
another one like in the middle of a
match yeah like what are you doing right
yeah so it's like it's they're really
really precise for the for the
conditions but I think it's worth it cuz
it's pretty dang cool also we are trying
to play it's just part of what is the
beta is uh getting into a match no
definitely don't cancel it cancel that
are you sure there's more playing casual
though is that what you've experienced
it does no no I am we are not doing
anything now so do you guys think that
kid Goku will be added to the roster I
don't know it's so like if you look at
the layout of like oh wait I can't even
talk about that is the layout in this oh
here we go
the layouts not even in this so I can't
even say that all right come on you just
want to play right come on that match
was so quickly didn't see it I know
right that we're doing the waiting for
opponent match all right here we go all
right just don't be shocked if we got
that red pink also did you pick that oh
that's my team oh that's fine
that's my team this is the cheese team
you should show them that that
one day one so quarter-circle forward
with projectile to do his like go adult
Gohan's like kamehameha
yeah and then you bring in dad
kamehameha then you do it again 15% that
easy like right on the battle see if
there yeah they call for it
are we gonna let these play you would
skip it all right we got five frame
delay oh you didn't get dad to come out
dad and then you're doing yeah yeah look
at that damage oh elbow people's elbow
so you didn't want to do the power up
after huh oh he wasted different
transmissions oh yeah get those balls
out all six of them what's he gonna do
so Richard was saying like a good thing
to do like a big dragon rush is to just
anti-air yeah just down yeah yeah yeah
cuz I think it has a lot of
invincibility yeah okay let me see if I
can do our reaction oh come on
oh yeah didn't taste down though oh so
that one is interesting like unless I'm
doing it wrong okay cool okay so you
know you can detonate it too yeah okay
it does take another meter at least from
what I know unless it's just animation
that might be able to tell me can you
switch between characters yes you can
switch out anytime you can also assist
you can also like DHC super in there so
yeah so he could call him in he could
technically super with Gohan yeah and
then like mid super he could just then
call like dad to come kamehameha piccolo
that sounds like that's boring for the
street food I caught the wrong at this
time Oh what do you what there you craft
that later but like what if like as you
as dad is hitting on goku's video you
Instant Transmission to the other
obvious destructive I destroy the little
internet spot yes you can
jacoub Instant Transmission hahaha yes
so two buttons
well Instant Transmission and it'll take
one meter too
[Music]
maybe that's not the right word is it
nation transition for the is it just
instant countrymen for the - pun for
that well what do they classify that as
but so you know how like you teleport
behind them yeah does that just
considered I might be making that making
that up because I'm so used to using
Goku in my life but what do they call
that in the game let's just call vanish
okay well I'm gonna call it instant
angry
Goku Black has interesting transmission
though
oh so yeah I guess you guys are right
about the lag it doesn't seem have you
felt anything oh okay he sparkled my
delay he says only five frames - so it's
not bad yeah oh god he's got so much me
oh you're gonna Sparkle on him yeah I
feel so close he like spamming the
button the thing is what the throws they
don't do a lot of damage
yeah I can't actually kill with them
charge on him he's not even
they call it super speed on the show
okay what's up pl3 yeah so hopefully
this guy rematches so we don't have to
sit in queue yeah but then he also got
his butt kicked so he might not but it's
casual
yeah casual okay I forget you can switch
your team in here right on a ream oh no
no you can't okay it's only off of the
okay oh he wants return the lobby told
you you looked them - sorry I didn't
even we didn't even swag on I'm too hard
is there a Goku Vegeta dramatic not that
we know we haven't seen it at least
there's one that I can't figure out and
I spent half a day trying to figure it
out I can't yeah we were you were Theory
crap yeah it's just theory crafting
based off the anime because they're all
anime moments right like so as mentioned
to get those dramatic finishes or intros
it seems like a level dependent thing
and then characters specific like
certain characters against other certain
characters yeah and so you know like
even before I saw the the cell Gohan
dramatic I was like dude I bet you
there's like at first I thought like you
had the level of three of them because
that's what he does that's a level three
right I was like oh what if you level
three cell that's probably how you
triggered the dramatic finish I was like
oh actually it's just a hard hit and it
triggers it which is fine same wafer
just fine are their taunts I'm not sure
I haven't found it yeah because he said
that typo glancing every arcs this game
has taunts doxa Fox's awesome cuphead
shirt by the way oh you know what I'm so
sorry guys I meant to go full game
during the gameplay so that we wouldn't
block anything I will do that next game
it took so long to get a game that I was
like oh I forgot it's my bad
is this guy gonna come on 27 seconds
left this is what happened to me ah
there we go
all right you're gonna eject in my first
my first connector then he realized I
want away oh you didn't your team again
that's fine I think no I think this
one's mine
no that's mine I think I also did that
oh you know your your team won this is
team two that's the one I'm in your team
one is different that's reason it oh
he's right I thought I could go on and
then go go in there somewhere a gaming
master asked are you excited for the
full release again yeah we are to me
it's a little sad that Monster Hunter
comes out the same day because I have to
decide but yeah we're totally so we've
been just excited since e3 when we got
our hands on that like very limited kind
of demo build that they had at e3 we
played off off of the stream for like a
good half an hour before Namco Bandai
had to take it away to the next
appointment can you link off of that off
of bringing and go through or not really
oh yeah err - Oh sounds a little bit
like it's only it's only one frame oh no
it's going on six to seven Erik is the
jido going to be PLC I have no idea the
Tito it's there's a lot of fusion
characters
what do you call the cheetah in a Goku
oh yeah here we go
second 13 frames now we're good
given the business got him yeah beerus
is a great character for this he doesn't
know the boos Oh stylish
Oh search form analyze me alright maybe
we should bring it bring up should we
bring up the the character is there an
arcade mode uh I mean I can't speak too
much outside of the beta just in case
for others sake other sub sakes so I can
only speak so much for this so this is
from the maker blazblue right Arkham
City our exes there is a story mode
though that's for sure alright your team
yeah I switch my okay we do that yeah
you have to hit start and then four
options and then go to yeah cool yeah
you're on standing bys see told you your
team's different yeah out of here I'm
copying that one that's like crazy the
crazy rank one guy master roshi DLC I
don't know I think they the best way to
get some of these more odd characters
that you might not necessarily want as
just a like playable character is what
they did with like ginyu force right
yeah I feel like they're gonna like
maybe they can integrate at that
somewhere that somehow that way we're
like the foam was of the world like ball
one comes out and like does something
they haven't announced any DLC like I
know I just don't think they've I know
it's any of the characters yet aside
from the blue harrods yeah and then now
yesterday confirming Android 21 as a
playable character who's like a boo
version Android 21 guys haven't seen
that oh wait
so season pass at eight new playable
characters we just don't know who they
are yet so that that's exciting but
there's gonna be eight we just have no
idea who they're gonna be it's just like
how 18 has 17 as part of her like it so
I go in some of them might be in there
just not as a fully playable character
is like
assist or something like that and then
the other thing that uh Peter wanted
that I don't know how easy it is to do
would be like more character type skin
so like Gohan might have like Seiya man
he has like this let me show you he has
like this costume yeah
like the say a man costume do you think
but would that like because I know there
are different versions of a single
character as like completely different
characters I'm just I'm just wondering
about the uh oh you got it someone that
knows how to play do we you just I don't
know man
you haven't gotten hit until now so
Julio was telling me that that elbow
drop is a good corner mix-up because
it's like hard to block both sides okay
he doesn't know what he's doing I lied
neither do I
oh sure you can
Freeza oh yeah Goku oh you don't Goku
dig
[Music]
Oh also there snapback guys just so you
guys know oh you're getting rekt no I'm
not pay attention my health bar uh-huh
oh it's a it's a mere match which one
are you though so yellow yellow one okay
you up case down yep yep and then give
them the business yeah
[Music]
was I grabbed yeah this is one of those
guys I feel like you can chase that like
with off that means all level three you
type that's level three level three yeah
that one's level three I'm pretty sure
the freezers got a lot of projectiles in
this kit which is pretty cool it's got
like Destructo just thing that can also
hurt himself but you can duck it yeah
and some of his uh his zoning things are
pretty cool yeah like yeah I don't know
what this one's called
[Music]
oh that can go far nice get out of the
corner yep
give them a super
oh it just doesn't rot a raw launcher
guess who's coming up next
oh yeah no but then he's gonna skip it
I think he's gonna skiddo if you put he
would wither yeah but he probably would
just mash buttons you dick no no okay
I'm trying it okay you're gonna stand
back a little bit Finny yeah all right
we're throwing this game to get
hopefully get that dramatic finish my
guess is this guy's gonna skip it
to kill me no milk I'm sure once he sees
it he probably he's probably seen it
only so that took extra meter by the way
you can't assume dude you be shocked
you'd actually yeah he activated the
sparking glass yeah for all you know
he'd mashed all the buttons to do that
bad ooh
all right fine just let me kill you then
all right
we're praying chat give me your power
spirit bomb power you guys can see that
I've put my hands up in the air
oh we're hoping that he gets it the
dramatic things he's going for it
how do you know why is he just Fanning
he's just doing hard okay okay
just stop attacking him then oh yeah
he's going for he knows did you Sparkle
though
oh it's again oh he's a level 3 that one
cuz he got Sparkle right now oh oh he's
trying
and you're making him feel like he
doesn't have it no is he gone for it oh
oh no what that was it though right I
thought that was a prerequisite was not
sure what happened we should have we
should have got there
rematch rematch yeah running back
saltiest of Rome Dex no we're almost
there - you attack too much no that was
it though that should have been it let
me switch teams give the folks something
else we've used a lot of Gohan beerus so
I made a bunch of teams at the bottom
that are like pretty good oh you know
what you could go a Crillon Crillon
Android I'll play them as I just want to
do the super where he goes right Android
Crillon and Vegeta do you know how to do
her level 3 though to get the thing it's
just as long as he's alive in your team
it's like Corsica oh yeah yeah sit we're
gonna try to get that alternative so
there's like alternate supers and stuff
you ruined it because he may have been I
think he I I I think he might have been
airborne on that ion though it had all
happened very fast and we aren't
gamestop so I don't know why they're not
streaming the Xbox one expert in play I
know Pro though
it's because you're on Namek destroyed I
thought it was Nanak destroy yeah it is
so they do have an intro on regular
dynamic uh-huh well it's a good day
ender yeah for the end it has to be a
finish destroyed version yeah makes
sense
funniest thing was like weird like
watching anime footage or I'm watching
anime footage and I'm like Joey what
does that look like to you is that like
a like our rocky field or trailer look
at the backgrounds of them and they're
like kind of nondescript like fields
kind of brown or like a little bit of
blue there so it's probably during the
day what I need to figure out is if I'm
gonna pre-order this before next week so
I can get the blues I know he probably
meant GameSpot and not Game Stop
I just purposely reverse told him that's
the point come on cuz they know you're
playing now I don't know anything with
these characters I'm gonna look as free
as those guys
[Music]
he gives them hair
I'll kill it
yes
frank says uh the Goku statue in the
collector's edition is the reason he's
buying that one we did just put up a
unbox young it's a look see a really big
green yeah statue mini statue so you
guys want to check that out that's also
a good spot calm yeah I don't think
we're gonna get skins either cyborg whoa
here's to hoping we'll see does I mean
like if there's different well I was
gonna say if there's different
characters like like I said different
individual characters for like a
different version of Oh Oh bad feeling
about this
he just has a good connection right now
I know but the names DP fighter man his
name is also purple wonderful yeah I
know I don't know what that means
what's the Z stamp it's like you do like
this huge almost like emotes like a
little sticker thing above you so you
can actually use those in the replay
channel and so while you're watching the
replay you can like during a moment you
can hit your stamp like when you want
when someone watches it you'll see them
all pop up at certain moments it's
pretty cool I think but I tend to turn
it on I'm just gonna watch the match see
see you wants to know where you got that
Cup petrol from go on to get the website
I think goes made by humans calm Soto
serious the beta is going on for another
six and half hours Bobby Bobby wrong
anime a Sun gun doesn't matter I know
you probably just sent his thing to
search and then went to go grab do
something something yeah I mean it is it
doesn't do the best indication I feel
like you'll be on the bottom yeah so
like you guys can see it cuz we're
walking but like it shows that where
that little magnifying glasses and then
it'll kind of like pop for a second and
say like match found and you have to hit
options to kind of like yeah I'm
straight doesn't just go into it
automatically and the thing is like
everything else you do stops you from
matchmaking it's like why not the
reverse then at that point like have
something on like the middle of the
screen that like you're like yeah I want
to
alert or something like that yeah yeah
it's it you can miss it easily like if
you're just looking away or don't have
audio on kala the square buyer names I
feel that's if we're in a match I
believe right
is it the green versus gobo versus white
no idea I'm gonna go with ping ping
that's right boys white scent oh no
actually that guy by the green squares
running around so I don't know
come on match make me did the metal gear
survive it alive yes oh we don't one we
played it this morning actually what he
canceled in hansel immediately uncle
fuzz is our connection bad no it can't
be
will do something yellow
come on it's most of it's probably
because the people with oh we're
connections are the more desperate ones
baby so there we go
chats telling us in settings we can make
it so that it Auto accepts magic okay
we'll take a look at that oh crap he's
got teen evil he's got four wins man hey
how come is that track oh we haven't
yeah
is this a real street fryer that we all
wanted this is more of the real marble
that we all wanted probably
let's let the show go how about they
ain't show go oh hey I bought you sir
oh [ __ ] it's not curling that front
there you go you just kind of standing
there I don't know what that does
I think it's like one of them is a
counter one of them is like a dash
attack and I should go with the third
one is careful kid boost I'm tricky
getting off film throw some bees or
rocks oh yeah yeah oh I didn't say if I
spam it maybe maybe you need another
meter for that I'm not sure
dammit well you're gonna grab that so
the beam it restores your blue health
and the worth is that either of either
you or the opponent can actually pick it
up no no no Crillon soul life - so like
as you can see I'm as good as Joey also
like I usually plan go
I wanted DHC but I think I gotta like
yeah I wasted it Oh into the volcano I
wasted the vanished punch for whatever
[Music]
all right you too Chuck you could charge
up your risk it risk free to hold light
and special at the same time I would say
bring in Android to to do that barrier
and then do it yeah oh yeah we owe a
while for this just come back
No oh you need the beam right now oh
that's a level three interrupted it
though great there we go yeah combo
didn't do it like a boss oh I thought I
wanted he saw so damn it
that was worth it though hundred fish oh
god I didn't get rid of us again alright
alright
you might you might want to run it back
though okay okay you can have to run
back do that : super sick I like it it's
a nice little touch rematch me come on
yeah salty runback who is the best at
fighting games of knowledge yes office
it depends on which game Richards pretty
good at fighting him so is a Joey
oh that was good you know like doing a
super - boom right from the top I don't
like the rain like what
well that crab is - slurps - hi tiny
guys
I like that I like that flash right
there oh it's anti Arizona yeah you can
do down down hard
oh just goes right through it
oh god I keep doing it on accident I
need the prints of saying
there we go it's like when they're in
that state you can do probably a super
weirdie like sliding on the ground got a
high-low mix up OT geez there are three
character combos not that I know if I
could try PhD at the crafts time that's
what before lysis can and sell beating
me up though kicking balls they use
0:03 I think you'll survive this
this is so good okay coke back up back
up back up
get that be thirsty again oh wow that's
so good but oh whoever touches it first
will get that dragon watching me I know
that's all you're doing and I should be
doing that more too
oh that was like four Destructo good
well tell owner yeah toes tempeh isn't
in the game seems like people are having
like some people are having like half an
hour weights in order to get it
it's probably probably has a lot to do
with people's uh location I'm thinking
some servers are better than others or
something like that try to borrow
Oh No look a two-hit combo dang it I
wanted the final jerk Oh destructive
finish Oh a little three alright well
probably I wish you could change your
team in here in the middle of a man you
should be able to change your team here
I think we'll jump out just so we could
switch teams I guess that's fine I was
trying to get the level three on him
I failed oh yeah I didn't do he has a
little like : does have the switcher
team by the way it's still searching the
his what's gonna call it the flash the
flash move what's the clan tag enemy if
I just GS if we have one their clans I
don't think so
I did not lobby
Krillin it that's right Phoenix forever
we are curling it for sure so if someone
said that we can change the in setting
the settings to auto auto there you go
start battle or battle there you go nice
thanks jammer
there we go
gamespot can you do a speculation bid on
the Dragonball Fighters beta is
speculation in what regards got to be
more specific I wish that became sage
enduring the fighter like the old dragon
balls where you had to turn Super Saiyan
that was another point that I think
Peter had brought up like that he's just
like I kind of want just like black hair
Goku or like black hair Vegeta and I'm
like within the game like during the
fight you then like you know maybe you
waste meter like yeah like golden Frieza
so powers are up so like you start at
base level but then you power up I think
so golden Frieza is one of those cases
where he gets buffer with a with like
using meter I'm pretty sure coke who
gets adult Gohan sorry
adult Gohan gets buffer with with the
with that super - yeah so bunker rock
piccolo nappa Crillon only the strongest
on this team ghost boy says if you like
fighting games and you like competitive
fires this is a must-buy I will say yes
however um did you read that thing that
uh Richard sent I think it was like a
game fax post or maybe his neogaf it was
one of the other about one person's
experience playing the beta right played
beta like you know matchmaking forget it
feels competitive or casual but either
way he played 27 matches in a row mm-hmm
and lost all of them lost and Alvin and
he said that because of like that
experience he's not behind the cane but
he says he blames the FTC because they
wrecked them because you couldn't like
land a punch either or something ooh
that was tricky so I figured out how to
end in sit near - in this game yeah it's
uh up and then like four four or
something up in dragon rush Oh
super-quick still gay porn or mix-ups
and stuff right oh yeah you need to do
that hurricane kick spa cutting just
like that yeah but doesn't that race
waster rush though so they don't want to
take it down again oh it doesn't so
you're saying you could just do that oh
boy we waited cell is a pretty interest
you were doing some work with him last
beta I remember uh some nice combos
we're not even th seeing that much
either yeah I know I'm just like oh yeah
three bars looks like he knows what he's
doing he's waiting for you to stand
Oh surprise full sports groom is also as
well attacks really dirty that won't
work just like doesn't look like his
foots there it goes underground stuffed
it nice rule oh you can punish bad at
nails launcher oh that's the old-school
marvel right there you cover the ground
and you cover the sky you're not going
to miss that reminds me of like the
Dante lasers oh there's the HC ringing
Goku save and he gets a powerup oh you
got to adapt Majin vegeta would be cool
i thought there would be some dramatic
things which would be them GUI because
it does exist
oh if you don't do it nice so you can't
you can't get chipped out which is a
surprise over oh oh the frames are going
he's turning on his delay because he's
afraid that we're gonna win
dang it he pulled his internet that's
what I'd like to think no we're good
we're good maybe hey guess SJ rose' Goku
black hey guys beta still working yes at
least for another 6 hours 6 hours 14
minutes guys
this guy's afraid he saw the power of
Goku you know you had smart he knew you
had sparkling still man
one group we should try rain I do it
yeah do it just to change your settings
yeah we're gonna get plugged cooled
that's what happens when you don't pick
high completion we got guys like that I
don't think he pulled his internet uh
Frank Delon asking is it better to play
fighting games with d-pad or analog I
personally use d-pad cuz I feel like I
get more control but that's just me I
think when whenever I play with
controller I have this habit of
switching between the two like for most
just like general movement I'll use this
d-pad button for like work afford
especially in certain I think to though
if I'm facing towards the Louie rights I
can't really do it too well so I use the
analog stick for those final flash anbu
which should be a dramatic finish with
fat food we tried that
it's not it doesn't work that way sadly
it doesn't work like you doing a level
three that would be cool actually uh I'd
rather there be like if there's already
stipulations why not even go the extra
mile to make it that way harder yeah
that's how it is in mortal combat
utilities require specific things for
you to do specific things and then you
have to end with a specific thing yeah
right whereas this is just like hard
kick or a heart like harder me but I
still need to get like that character on
this stage in the lat in the plant but
it's like an easter egg
Oh what chicken down Mac and out no oh
there's the defecate er punk rock says I
use d pad because I can't DP on Dragon
Punch for [ __ ] on stick yeah there used
to be a way to kind of cheat the DP and
on she fire you could just do diagonal
diagonal in the whole motion that was a
shortcut
yeah I mean fighters doesn't have too
many complex like motion so there's like
a lot there's maybe like a handful of
down down movements
I know Frieza has one feel like a
teleport but they're all it's all core
scible corsica forward or back yeah
are you changed in Napa yeah at the
cabbage I get some exercise some of
these yeah these are all walled off here
I want to know what that one is it's a
calm a house does ginyu seem broken
I haven't played enough of him honestly
to tell you anything about getting you
other than I think it's cool that like
his intro is cool and stuff like that
would you say this is a must-buy I mean
it's hard to say I mean if you like
fighting games especially like
team-based ones right and you like
Dragon Ball Dragon Ball helps you if you
if you like those two things I think
it's a for-sure by if you like Dragon
Ball and like fighting games now if
you're one or the other it's a little
harder to say and if you don't
necessarily like Dragon Ball or fighting
games it's probably a harder sell
because I feel like fighting games feel
once a niche but there's definitely a
demographic right there's fighting there
tend to be like that
I guess that barrier of entry for not
not necessarily for this one but just
fighting games in general yeah like you
know just knowing what your how to do
certain things in order to and in order
for your experience to be enjoyable yeah
I mean they like as fighting games have
evolved though there's there's mechanics
in the games and the the later like
these newer games that try to help
assist that so like easy combos or
things like that but yeah it can be
daunting you know especially if you play
someone that knows what they're doing
you know you play five to ten matches
and this beta maybe you get smashed
because people know what they're doing
it kind of becomes demoralizing she was
like do you have the spirit to kind of
keep going however I will say there is a
single single-player story experience
that's I think I want to say like ten
hours plus or something is that around
ten hours
so like you at least get you'll at least
get that if not just all this stuff on
the side to you know
not to mention the game is beautiful
yeah it looks awesome so amazing to look
at yeah I mean you're not even a Dragon
Ball fan I know nothing serious at all
but I love Marvel Marvel 3 and this is
like as close as I'm gonna as it for me
at least like infinite was wasn't as
like oh it just wasn't as faithful to
the series in my mind boards this one is
it's so much closer to what I like in
Marvel notified you should be able to
find it on a PlayStation Store or the
Xbox Live Store
I think it was in the free section for
PlayStation let's try some other stuff
ten-hour story mode and a fighting game
yeah it's pretty long there's like
multiple arcs I think is how it works I
can't speak to too much about it other
than some of that stuff but you know
it's it's just cool to have more out
there for people that experience and
play I think injustice did injustice to
you did a great job of that
Hey and just as to was it one of those
games that I think got more people than
I thought it would
maybe that's because a lot of people
like DC and there's an experience for
them for like there's a story also like
the multiverse I thought was pretty cool
like I actually really enjoyed my time
playing against a computer like getting
gear and leveling up and just
customizing everything Oh Frank Dillon
says we need an R so Fighters I don't
know I actually like the Naruto games
quite a bit even like for what they are
like they're they're like 3d fighting
but I I don't know I liked it I liked
the Naruto series a bit the way it is so
I think the FA is fine for it to not
have some of this
go low on him get the Pete Joey he
doesn't know about the disappearing foot
who this guy knows combos oh do you
think he's trying to combo you again
after the after the work the wall down
that was me oh you're a Goku oh my bad I
thought you were playing kid gusto I was
like that's a nice combo turns out it
was Joey my bad so I got goku kaboom so
so that first day I was playing I was
burning so much meter just DHC because
it just looks so cool to have three like
of your characters on screen doing like
a super oh wow freaky oh that was oh no
no no okay that is like one of the best
like Counter supers or just like kind of
cheap supers in a way because he does
Instant Transmission sha-3 Goku Instant
Transmission in the Kamehameha so like
if they're pressing a button or doing
anything towards you he will teleport
behind and basically get that suit level
3 super off how are you playing as
Cameron Phelps the open Vedas oh wow
oh no stability I was about to grab
and my fullscreen guy he knew yeah we
knew that kid we like to do that like
this is so cheap it doesn't take out
that much lifestyle and it's not like
you can connect off of it so I don't
want I don't want to classify anything
that's cheap because everyone everyone
on the screen of them in here on the
screen is gonna yeah Marvel stuff is
cheap when's marvel there's some dirty
stuff in the corner man we just we just
don't have that technical screen you
can't touch a button yeah but he can
jump up and dragon rush here that's why
you cover it cover yourself appearances
oh yeah we got four of the seven
dragonballs right now oh so the fun
thing about that super is even though
you've blocked the first part of it
it'll subtle comes down so you got to be
careful but you can actually go dragon
rush past it if you're fast enough
that's it
Rito in it oh you're gonna lose
everything okay yes we are on PSN about
inverse game beta is over on Xbox really
why would it be different than PSN what
was it all three I was just like a super
so we are won't actually one Dragon Ball
way forgetting all right it's the last
one so that's 70 hit yeah yeah 70 hit
combo I don't think that's gonna happen
here not with the one character you talk
just do it full screen he's tired of
your our first loss he does have a lot
of battle points and yeah he does he was
not that good for that maze I plan on my
opinion yeah we got that wasn't I think
you I mean I see if I could get that
one's pretty easy I like it a win gives
you 2500 pre-match okay let's do it
alright take them out take it
then I'm gonna 70 hit combo next I mean
like sure I don't like it's hard with
just one character I think you need to
be able to THC to get a 70 hit
are you missing like a special nerve
there at there oh no that's him plane
could be mother oh nice yep Oh - leg
injury
oh we wasted neither oh just do it nice
yeah that's like the Gohan Goku stuff
right there does that work oh you
shouldn't press buttons
no I can't Oh a little through be
destructive you don't need a 70 hit just
seven what for 14 28 21 28 it's a
multiple of seven I don't know that's
what punk rock saying listen Nicole I'm
so sad why later hoopla you're Brown he
is brown blue oh okay I'll do this nice
baited him on that one you probably
thought you're gonna spam it again
Connor got close my hat you're losing
though my life
I'll sell come on no coverage
Goku Auto combo seven hint so it always
gives you a dragon ball oh I like it
yeah give him the hug Oh get out of here
elbow sparkly the damage is here now
that's an overhead oh yeah give him one
of your own
all right he's got sparkling sparking
goes for a long time there's no way out
Tekken rush see if you can track her
suit oh yeah just wrong oh he didn't
sparkling finis sparkling Sparky barking
blasts I'm just gonna call this fight
thing sparkling sounds better are they
both playing or just one's just watching
I'm watching he's playing because
there's no local in the beta so
unfortunately that's how it goes okay so
one one right yeah one one one one let's
see if he rematches if he if he has true
honor he'll fight us again yeah all
right you want to go for the ss3 here
yep
oh gotta punish that yep yeah that's
fine I feel like that's a waste of
meters but you only want to use what
you're like avoiding like getting out oh
happy birthday oh that's some day one I
like that the day one confirms Tommy
Holly Honda Super Cub yeah
[Music]
oh I think you just gotta watch out for
so I think protip is like for anyone
watching I think if you see a launcher
whiff you want to punish yeah if you can
oh there you go he tried to blind and
run can that work he scooped off the
wall bounce I'm not sure what moves
actually I know you've super it off the
wall bounce but I don't know if I've
ever seen you
oh wow did I place did anyone play final
down on ps1 back in the day it sounds
very familiar
I'll cry if I summon Shenron and my
opponent rage boots
his meters filling out fast he's not
doing anything
oh he was colleges wasting on like
specials because if you do some specials
with hard
Oh
Oh No
oh you so like what you didn't finish
you off
alright just realize your whole team can
do like the car mija mija essentially oh
that work it's gonna kill pls destruct
in minish nice Alonso Alfonso sorry land
a ver day can we play fighters on xbox
right now I would assume so somebody
told me that you it's it's over well I
really like the the beta for Xbox right
now is only offline oh really
yeah that's what that's why I heard I
did not know that all right let me take
a look oops it's a monkey GG man I got
six thousand beep beep it up
so when ya winning would give you more
right so it's okay no check a Bandai
Namco's Twitter because I think they
post right there
Oh offline trial mode or an Xbox long so
I guess they're having copters
sorry guys Sal has got great reach at
GameSpot don't underestimate that I
don't I did not underestimate him fellas
some pretty good normals it's like the
smaller characters sometimes like I hate
that reach Crillon and god damn reach is
so like hey here's a good combo a solid
triangle triangle square
oh no it's sir Oh circle I can't really
dark circle I came to see how much
longer is open beta going on for another
six hours [ __ ] old 9 o'clock Pacific
Standard Time or Daylight Time I'm not
sure this every time so when am I gonna
get my green circle or greasers
characters let's get some napa I think
we got an a Pettine down there somewhere
piccolo 2 we have a napa piccolo I
probably even doing that but now piccolo
and who else didn't we play we played
everyone else if you played everyone
okay these are bad guys let's go we'll
get lucky with Namek again destroyed do
you guys have your own YouTube channels
no we don't at least I don't do you well
I mean like I have one but not like it
like I don't do anything on it used to a
long time ago but stop doing that noctus
the beta still going on on ps4 and I
guess there's offline trials for Xbox
nappin know how what can you do in this
hub lobby there's a tutorial stuff at
the bottom there's a replay Center
there's matchmaking and I think there's
a check ranking and rankings
yeah not awful lot yet but um last I
mean all these like walled off areas
will be open
it'll have stuck there I think someone
earlier I forgot who it was and the chat
was saying look at the tower there's
like a little tower over here I'm not
sure what it is yet but this one's also
walled off so it'll be available in the
full game here
also just so you guys know you don't
necessarily have to like walk around
this area just to trigger like the
matchmaking or the replay Center you
could technically just hit like options
and it'll let you do a bunch of stuff in
there I believe also like I think also
warp up yeah red ping get hike okay
although I think we've only had one
that's gone really bad but like even all
the red and no way you know it wasn't
that bad yeah they've been fine so chat
didn't technically totally lie to us
oh man this guy's hey okay what's his
name I can't see
I think it's Jeff jefe it's not a very
big download urban Messiah so I think
that if you just downloaded it again
still be able to potentially play a play
for the next six hours a single piece
for two and a half gigs yeah it's like
two and a half the exam
Maximillian how do you get the beta go
to the Xbox Live store or PlayStation
Store and get that hot Dragonball
Fighters beta of course yeah your
desired fight conditions were not met
there's something like boy this
wonderful
[Music]
I'm gonna show you guys the dramatic
finishers but that might be tough
oh here we go we don't need that all
right I am going to put a game now
see you guys oh they got a piccolo DV
fighter rocking like a very vanilla team
are you sure that's the the default name
P V fighter he's got 42,000 points
though five zones oh I already have what
10,000 something yeah sure hi again so
how are you and just call me Jeff we're
doing pretty well Jeff thanks for tuning
in
call me Jeff is that was that the guy
that Jonathan left our game I can't play
it says no connection than networking
okay so what's Alexis Napa's deal
exactly if you came with Vegeta he's
part of the over 9000 little dank meme
hey oh yeah he's not even playing he
probably left his on and like oh no he's
back a there we go
look at your honor you fight with honor
doughy
despite be anymore that work coward
wow that's awesome to combo is we could
have texted foot and that's just that's
shown when it's blue right the combo Oh
duck it so those are the disks I was
talking about that he had that Frieza
has that will come back and potentially
hurt you
you're not careful oh he's afk again man
come on BB fighter Hey
he's like eating I want to have to do
this just beat him up and rematch okay
swag on
beauty
yeah piccolo I didn't die low short
cause he gave me a choice between sub
and dub this English the English voices
are who that elbow is so dirty
I don't know what this has there it's
like if the trawler kept dying maybe he
made this and when she's playing with
one hand trying to fly at the same time
yeah maybe
Melissa's community has asked when will
gain sauce review of the game be up fine
actually game releases Mary Jeanne -
what's up barolay spots are you
rematch he's still eating a sandwich
yeah now he's using both hands hit it
with my foot okay there we go
I just uninstalled it installed it
against a failed to connect to the metal
for mine it's fine I'm sorry to hear
about the good maybe the campus combo is
oh yeah reflectively
oh maybe he's back she stopped eating a
sandwich wow that does so much damage
without the secret
sorry check out how am i doing I'm like
are you gonna let him turn reflect yeah
get that out of here
okay yeah I don't think
there we go get around here very dead 14
waiting as dragon longer if she's saying
it's just server under maintenance for
him I don't know where PlayStation that
I've been on for like an hour
whoa
go chase down
how do you start a versus no you can't
invade uh-oh
Oh Oh get serious now that is a corner
trap like yeah yeah sorry if they're on
Xbox unfortunately there's only like
those trials matches i think is what
Namco came and said so fortunately for
y'all
in China reflecto I just love doing it
though
Oh
that's weird so the Goku thank you it's
like it looked like piccolo is in front
o a Cyberman
I don't even know what's going on
it's like that feels on be for Marvel
[Music]
number three got toes got the toes yeah
it'll be up till 9 p.m. it's still
trying
what I'm doing there [ __ ]
it's Joey's bread and butter once a dick
you go get blown up how do you play
against somebody had to matchmake SAP
Kaplan Kaplan just go towards the
matchmaking I've won two games or two
matches
oh so you can only play them twice yeah
so yeah best 2:03 so this is what you
would do we're gonna switch the team
again yeah also to use to yours I'll
play something else
it doesn't matter do you want any of
these premades
yeah actually yeah I just go to my team
I want to mess around do this I don't
even know how to do the ball thing I
only know how to do the one where it
shoots around his body that gets horse
or a Ford special that's the one that
has six of them right yeah but then what
do you do to make them like go all over
the place or like to like push them
forward
oh you just you just like doing normal
attack oh and he hits the ball water hit
them or if you do core circle back and
special he does the one where he like
shoots them all out and like all
directions who's your favorite character
[Music]
I mean right now I really like go tanks
he's not available in the beta willing
in the full game he's I think it he's
really cool he has a lot of like
high-priority moves very flashy he's
also really really tiny but he's like
his right his moves have like good
priority which is always nice
urban messiahs is Crillon from the beta
for me god I guess beerus but he's like
a god i think that cain is that so good
my favorite dragon but I know who you
are and I will say like I'm not going to
comment on that Faden know it's like I
don't know Drago you're four four five
oh yeah so happy that I got to catch the
stream from work again
thanks ichigo kurosaki are you ready for
this yeah
I see on the ground
watch out for those overheads okay guys
hi
get out of here dad you have to go
mystic on them oh crap
and then dragon rush yeah he's getting
out of there I can't I always don't do a
good job fine
when I got back in the corner
ah crap
you go he'll be beers or Spears
you have to grab just uh kicking them
around
so I think after if you do that dive you
can do is level three right after
oh the spam super it's all good I
brought 119 says stop the beta was over
you thought wrong it's back some been
dynamical actually brought it back for
24 hours starting last night just to
kind of make up for the problems that
the connection problems that they had
earlier man oh did he did he not no
rematch come on I'm a day one baby I
just know how to press press 1 2 3
really well and so yeah the beta is
gonna be going on for another 24 hours
starting last night so it's gonna end at
9 p.m. Pacific tonight which is in about
5 hours 45 minutes I want to be hercule
want to be though you say that now and
then we get some of these random
characters as actual characters and then
nobody plays them and then what then
you're just you wish that they had a
real character instead you have like a
Marvel two problem where you throw
everyone in there but only half the cast
is you and a Karras I never played any
case actually anything my weirdest
character was in Marvel there's a long
time where I was like I'm gonna make
Mero good oh god she's bad or a Mingo Oh
he plays marvel i buy marvel
[Music]
you see I guess whenever they're having
server issues people were just lining up
as the same character like across like
we're doing like I saw the whole ring
over the same care or whole ring of
beerus as i think
are you gonna go with oh you can always
edit them to you that's she gotta hate
everything though
we'll go at the napa cabbage
it will have local multiplayer okay well
so you can play your friends but how can
you not have a local multiplayer in the
fighting game where we get salty in the
mines goo wanted a local tournament for
engaging SWAT officers the whole day I
don't know about the whole day but maybe
Maximilian dude has an amazing a Mingo
I've I haven't seen it yet he always
plays it like on his uh his like
throwback Oh what that guy's Oh what oh
you can do yours East damn triangle yeah
but a pause is match my
it's weird though that didn't the other
beta beta have assessed the other Gohan
young Gohan the original oh yeah that
first Emily my crazy I think so
mystic Gohan that'd be kind of crazy
Napa has killed his dad on the web at
the book fold
she's play team ball
piccolo Crillon and Napa about freeze it
technically I guess they're yeah but how
often is he actually wind bake a pie man
is he went a lot with Mingo I think he's
pretty good it's been a while since I've
seen his marvel two videos but back when
he was like plain playing them online
you've got 18 we've got nine matches
with two wins if I lose I'm gonna walk
off this oh this is our chance to rank
up we can get that green square we've
been hoping for
oh is that what it is yeah why are you
running circles because I'm waiting for
matchmaking ooh get some RP oh oh you
skip my shirt get off
that's smart actually because that's
holding block yeah it's like mixing up
those dragon listen got anti-air hurt
dude that's actually really good
I tried to I guess so Richard was saying
you could um
tag in I thought I'll swap in a meter so
I was trying to do that but I guess it
doesn't work it should work today I'm
gonna have to walk off the screens over
no you come back right here you got use
it basically you have to use his tactics
against him so so you guys start mixing
in those throws when he least expects it
right now
you're not you're pressing button
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
now see button beat him out
oh dang there we go is this a comeback
does it come back alive we'll see a
cyborg that says they should maybe Napa
fight like Zangief luckily they have
Android 16 he's uh who is actually
properly
oh good love good love if you meant to
do it he's fishing for those throws I
assume
I don't mean to be I think it's like if
you do medium and hard it doesn't
teleporter no it's great I still have
the West 7 meters don't have to oh my
god you still have the life leave
unfortunately go plate sink you sitting
on all the places doesn't seem to want
to use any of it I would spark I was
trying
okay looking good even though he does
have seven bars this uh okay
oh no you can follow that up
you know run it back it's this level
three not quarter circle back it should
be yeah then maybe I could match it out
see hit a whoa whoa whoa calm down we
still rank up we still rank them out
wait we lost but we you still get points
we got 10,000 all right maybe I'm not
good with Napa oh I like that
there we go Swamiji he loves hunting so
that engages at the Trotec but though I
think you can hit them out of it or you
can also throw at the same time all
right up to the games with this guy Joey
will do that clash will do like this
it's like we switched characters what we
do or switch down secure your [ __ ]
Frieza
oh yeah plant those whoo going those
nice
[Music]
yes I mean he switched people food oh
why didn't that cover my escape I was
gonna hurt Daniel sparkly
okay that his teacher will take care of
him
[Music]
okay Sparky's gone for him
well I didn't reach him
finally uses it here
yeah alright alright alright best of 3
vesta - his teacher don't you mean is
that no no I mean piccolo is Gohan Gohan
to old teachers Joey did you know that
though
Babu has a unique super for every
opponent I didn't know that oh here we
go I gotta focus I gotta focus guys I
gotta walk off this stream if I lose I
think so for majin buu oh I think what
cyborg man is talking about is as level
3 wendy is law turns into a cook suit
and that cookie looks like a little
miniature version of that character I
was like a pretty cool soul Easter eggs
I think we're not using it just like so
usually assists after the teleport
advantage I just have to out scamming
yeah is what I've realized it's just
King spider what's up overhead
everywhere you know you know we actually
were able to eat since we have a feel
gave me dude
do not spend some time with Goku black
rose I think pretty boys level three get
around seeing it
cyborg man says be prepared to walk I
don't think so taze got a pretty good
life lead right now
crap this [ __ ] is catchy with those
throws swim
I just have to try to out spam him but
he's gonna switch characters now in jail
white back which is people not eating
jumpers oh my god it's like either spam
or dislike dragging it out found I think
I'll need to do more yeah look took down
heavy we'll get you that invisible super
or is he beautiful
counter so anytime you see him
anytime you see dragon record my dragon
it's super - I'm pressing the button
oh my bike my backhand with alright see
you guys with punished it's good now you
guys know it's a sauce parking so you're
still in this now it's good knowing you
guys no not yet
yeah how do you do the fireball into the
thing your children watercourse it in
the air Corsica for special hope he'll
throw that the pink one down on deck oh
no no sparkling save me
alright see you guys it was good knowing
you guys rich oh you're not in the
stream right yeah alright bye guys
so sad don't play characters you don't
know alright
he's got it he's got it so it gets us
only me now all right let's go back in
let's see how much time do we have how
much time do we have Joey I think we
have maybe about like maybe time for one
more match so let's see if we can get
that in oh there we go
should have probably changed my
characters before this but I guess I
will work with what we always given to
me
let's see we have cannot read his name
Cyberman unfortunately yes he did give
up
remembering Daigo Evo 37 yes always
[Music]
okay this guy is timing out so I'm gonna
go quickly change characters hopefully
we'll get one more match
do they have a majin buu avatar for the
lobby I don't think they have it right
now yeah these are only the characters
are in the in the beta at the moment
I'll just be doing laps here until we
get actually get the match in the stream
Casey vlogs hello thank you for joining
us on there on the tail end of our
dragon ball fighters dream if you're
just joining and are still wondering how
to actually get into the beta if you
knew or if you would call a the beta was
actually extended one extra day starting
last night at 9:00 p.m. it's gonna go
for 24 hours until tonight at 9 p.m.
Pacific which is in about five hour five
and a half hours so you still have good
amount of time to get some matches in
and does a full game have online party
mode to invite friends yes most likely
it will now I can't imagine a fighting
game that you would not be able to
invite your friends into to play will we
get one more match
[Music]
even though they don't change my avatar
maybe that's giving us some bad luck so
we'll go with Frieza
do they have Pikachu now no I pretty
sure you're playing the wrong game
our Demong well this is the pokemon crap
that you might be referring to is just
the characters and that's just in the
lobby but in actual gameplay itself it's
a lot more fun more flashy than this
[Music]
I don't want to pause my matchmaking
and give myself some hair here
there we go
hey yes you did leave your drinking here
leave it on the side so it'll spill or
anything
[Music]
[Music]
oh there we go please hope we can
actually get connection on this guy
I think if I'm read his name right he it
looks like it's the same guy who refused
last time so he might still be just
eating a sandwich or something
[Music]
ma man
all right if he doesn't accept this I'm
gonna go change it to casual match
probably for the last one let's see if
we can get that that much done a little
bit faster
okay
casual let's do it one bar is fine
Marko's key is if you don't play dragon
ball games at all it will for me at
least like I am NOT in dragon ball at
all I know nothing about the series but
I've been just so drawn to this game
just mostly because of how just flashy
it is and how fast pace and that's kind
of like what I really like in fighting
games so I think it's definitely worth
at least a look you know download the
beta and just try it out for yourself I
guarantee you'll get at least some
enjoyment out of just seeing the
characters move and the animations
because it's pretty pretty great
[Music]
Lord ghosts in gaming uh says they fix
the lag when fighting actually in the
matches that we've been able to play
today in the matches that we've been
able to play today there hasn't been a
lot of lag at all like even with
opponents that I've only said that
they've said they are only a one-bar
connection it's been it's all been
pretty good Bob Jones what DLC
characters
oh he's I can guess key tales like I am
not the best person to ask which DLC
characters to to put into this game all
right Casey bugs yep thanks for thanks
for tuning in I appreciate it
no I have not gone to match and Tay has
returned for his drink so there are
actually 11 fighters in the beta right
now in the full game there are 24 I
believe oh what was that it says Anna
poll was found but then they cancel it
right away
like I haven't that happened every time
yeah
or actually a couple of times they've
just it's just run it run the clock out
alright well I'll give you 5 more mins
to get a mad okay now we'll probably
just call it a day
no it's not Kirby slayer the beta is
open for everyone that has I would
assume you need at least PSN though at
some point it's gonna be on PC I don't
know what the date is though is it you
know on the same day yeah so 26 26 PC
Xbox Playstation 4 just PC was not
involved in the beta that's all yeah
beta is 2 and 1/2 ish gigs I've got they
didn't want PC they liked and almost
never do PC betas cuz like it always
gets data mine yeah stuff just gets data
money need a match so we don't end on
taking rekt wow you know what dude I
can't wait to play you one-on-one and
what's do with me yeah we'll see who
wins cuz you know what I would have
instantly did what I would have just had
Goku at the back just level 3 instant
translation yeah cuz he was spamming so
much I could like I knew I had a defect
like that's such a defensive super it's
like really easy to like just use but
okay I'll go cool my team just like yeah
you wanna you want to press buttons all
right here you did level 3 coming how
many huh and I want to on the game easy
would've work although you know what I
was trying to do just now - as Frieza
his level 3 is like when he's down I
think I supposed to like you down-down
something like I think he does the level
3 wake up super on the ground I feel
like that's that's well no it's so 5050
though at least with with uh Goku Z at
least goes behind them yeah
instantly so they can't really is so
hard to block that whereas you they meet
you basically need to read them and see
like oh are they attacking me on wakeup
fine I'll do my level three and then I
didn't um I should have golden and ever
Golden's which is a problem with reason
yeah I'm not I don't remember what Oh
what golden does
yeah
man Oh Brandon says after playing marvel
internet for a long time or marvel
infinite a long time the game is
confusing because uh 3v3
that's kind of the opposite for me
because I played Marvel 3 for a long
time and then infinite came along they
shaped they switched it up and brought
it back to 2v2 I was like what's going
on so that's why I've kind of taken such
a liking to this game just because it is
3v3
just as flashy as Marvel 3 was it's hard
for us to show the amaze it's hard to
show the characters Alexander because
it's not like a traditional or like you
pick your characters it's like we have
to kind of like pre pick them ahead of
time like set our teams guys when you do
is he has to 228 we have 69 all right
this is the last match to end it
hopefully if not God Karthikeya
[Music]
Oh off transmission you can dragon
rocket yes
and walkthroughs with super dashes
dragging her spent okay he's blown it
yep
that feels like a waste to me cuz he can
adjust chase without having to waste a
meter but I guess each other's here yeah
I feel like aggression paid off or
earlier before tech gets to get us and
then here you have me and Joey who don't
want to spam that because cable NBC's
new cable oh nice for dick
oh I saw what damn man
without your string
the good news is these out of sparkling
sparkling super Daphne all over the
place oh good stuff
boom are your level two now sighs don't
try to reflect it
[Music]
no three leaders in here oh my god
yes the ESPE I don't know we're going to
the islands now apparently don't forget
yes [ __ ] dad Saints Park constructed
these guys looks like they eat tied pots
yeah they're delicious don't actually go
anytime
okay I did but you can use it to stuff
up boys Frank okay it's okay you got
sparking nope just smashing down the
Camilo all right right back
he's scared
you want a rematch he's going you know
you can win this you know you want to
wait another 10 minutes for a single
match
we've got 12 seconds to decide that
maybe wait huh uh Kirby Slayer he's
played a bunch from other betas he had
the game kind of in did he back out he
just looked the clock right now probably
want to go now he didn't use must he did
my Senko in - so the combo of emo Sanko
into Goku assist into my Cinco
so you can land that and that's like 15%
all right unless you happen to get one
fast we're gonna have to call well uh of
course can't read the name it's not
Camilo though you two are my dad's now
is it bedtime yeah bedtime will come
after this match or this fifty second
countdown where we don't get into okay
there we go
he's he's got a pretty high winrate 14
and 16 yeah
this ends EST 12 a.m. Caleb so 9 p.m.
Pacific 12:00 a.m. Eastern but it's
really only working online on
PlayStation
there's trial stuff on that see this guy
is like the opposite of all those other
guys you're playing he's like yeah he
didn't think we do it three times in a
row putting a technical game in Oh does
that work what he just did what was it
he threw the rocks and then he insta re
vanish punched
Oh
oh and then you'll assist in okay
this guy's pretty good guy know some
time all right now you got it oh no it
was close
thank you okay
Oh on the way down they also this
assisted yeah all right this is some
[ __ ] we're learning we're now learning
oh hello watch the toes we got that see
right down
[Music]
we have found our thousand words
two nice boys it's refreshing to see
some actual high level play just like
typical animal okay we're doing it we're
going in full Sun nice okay it's at the
hotel in the building
don't worry oh we got we're only two
dragonballs away we might be able to
revive a hero here
okay
oh I wonder if you needed to use the
meter to vanish good again hopefully he
lets you run at that I want that right I
want it
start okay skip the outros he's like I
wanna play this game readings going in
ooh man I got a I got a get those those
combos and gotta learn I think I need to
be a little bit more patient
oh not like this okay
huh
you don't have to be HP well if that's
what you're trying to do
and you gotta just give us on the way
day 1 new strategies
don't be sad with that dragon roughly
learning quick give me your energy
please gonna stay back a little bit okay
[Music]
oh don't press buttons
[Music]
see ya
you drive left visa anytime
no Beatrice aka bill Courtney because
this helps against I'm doing the know or
the vanishing against the finish yeah oh
yeah I like the thought
wake up 11
got him I think you got him thank yous
questions I'll just do it
oh my god the damage don't let him out
oh good job it's the six ball corner
strategy here come get us that guy's
pretty good alright thanks guys for
tuning in to our Dragonball Fighters
open beta stream its up for another five
hours or so on PlayStation online Xbox
has like that trials battles you can do
game comes out next week so we're
excited to look forward to playing that
will play it on release date which is a
twenty six sure Jeremy will be back here
possibly myself and then tomorrow we got
Monster Hunter beta there's another beta
from Monster Hunter so Monster Hunter
world the last one the last beta 4 comes
out next week and yeah it's gonna be fun
time so make sure you guys come back
tomorrow if you want to see some more
beta action if not next week we got
monster Monster Hunter world of course
Dragon Ball has mentioned and probably
some other stuff in the works
there's on Tuesday that I can't remember
but just come back we're streaming every
day except for Wednesday's here and
there at 11:00 a.m. Pacific thanks so
much Joey for playing yeah thanks for
having me
one fun yeah a lot of fun thanks go
thank you so much guys have a good one
goodbye bye bye see ya
[Music]